[Music]
hello everyone
so as mentioned in the at the end of
our previous lecture we'll be starting
our discussions on deformable bodies
from this lecture onwards so first of
all we note
that the configuration of
a deformable body
that is the configuration of a
deformable body
that is defined
in terms of
delta u which is the first variation
of the displacement okay so uh do you
understand that i mean this
uh in the vector form
so within it is subsumed the three
components
delta u1 delta u2 delta u3 so in index
notation as we had been discussing in
our previous course of applied
elasticity
uh this is equivalent to
delta ui all right so now we consider a
body in equilibrium
so our plan here is basically to apply
the principle of virtual work
uh on a on a body or to a body
which is under equilibrium under the
action of
traction and body forces okay so
consider
a deformable body under equilibrium
under the action of traction and body
forces
so as we had mentioned at near the end
of previous of the previous lecture
what we have for the principle of
virtual work is delta w equal to 0
and that can be decomposed into the
contributions from the internal forces
and the external forces
and what we have is this statement that
delta w i that is to
the work done the virtual work done due
to the internal forces
is a negative of the virtual work done
due to the external forces
okay so this by itself the statement
this equation by itself it represents
the principle of virtual work
now when we apply this to the uh to a
deformable body in equilibrium
under the action of traction body forces
this external
uh bit that can be represented
in some in some familiar terms like this
that rho b is the contribution from the
from the body forces so that is dotted
with delta u vector this is over the
entire volume
and over the surface we have the
contribution from the fraction
of which i represent by this capital
e vector that is dotted
with delta u and this integration is
over the surface
okay so you understand that these
displacements
are disputed over the entire volume and
this displacements
pertain only to the surface of the on
the volume
all right now
we are going to do some manipulations on
this so that
this principle of virtual work applied
to the deformable body
it comes out in in us in a in a
form which is more manageable and
uh more amenable for further discussions
down the line
and we'll be discussing a number of
proper applications which will set us up
for
which will allow us to solve a very
interesting
engineering problems okay so towards
that end
we are we are a little bit uh we are
quite distant actually
from that stage uh where we can actually
use these energy methods
to solve problems but but as a first
step towards that
let us try to uh to recast this
principle of virtual work applied to
deformable bodies you know something
of something more manageable and
amenable
all right so we'll be doing a number of
steps
now first of all we just
convert this to the index notation
just to make things easier for us
now uh the plan is
that we we wish to make this make these
expressions as simple as possible
now the main difficulty that lies
immediately in our path
is that we have two different
integrations in the form of volume
integral and surface integral
so as we have done uh quite a few times
earlier especially in our courses of
applied elasticity
uh we'll be converting we'll be trying
to convert this surface integral
into a volume integral and for that
uh what we'll do is we'll first use
uh something which we have been
repeatedly using in our previous course
of applied elasticity
which is this relation that the traction
is given
in terms of the stress and the normal
vector
so ti is equal to sigma ji nj
okay so we'll substitute this back here
the first term remains as it is and the
second term
that becomes sigma ji
nj delta ui
ts
now uh what we wish to do now
is that see this basically
is uh
so you can think of it in this fashion
that it is sigma j i delta u
i uh that multiplied with this
nj so sigma ji together with delta ui
that particular entity sigma gi delta ui
that particular entity has within it the
i index
repeated so that is basically a vector
with the index j
and that when multiplied with n j that
kind of represents
uh that represents uh the the dot
product
okay so uh so what we'll do
is we can just
rewrite this
we'll go to the next page now we'll
rewrite this
delta w e
again the first one remains as it is
the second one we'll write this together
okay just just a little bit of a change
we'll write this together put the
bracket to make things very explicit
and then nj ds
so you see whatever this entity is it is
a vector and that is uh
that is given by the index j and that is
dotted with this n vector
okay so uh
can we not apply the gauss divergence
theorem
on this term to convert whatever this
is into a volume integral so what i'm
saying is
this particular integral you can think
of it
as integration some vector v
j because sigma j i delta u i
is equivalent to some vector v j
n j yes so this is basically
like this is equivalent to p
vector dotted with n hat
which means this can very well be
converted
to a volume integral using the gauss
divergence theorem
okay so this is equal to
delta of v the divergence of the v
vector
so please note that this and this fee is
maybe
i should uh just write it like
in a slightly different kind of v
otherwise it is becoming confusing with
this volume
this v for the volume okay i hope uh
none of you would mind this
so this is now a volume integral and
that
can again be converted to the index
notation so let me write this down here
directly
this becomes a volume integral now and
this is sigma i will keep this as it is
okay so sigma j i delta u
i now that
we have to carry out the divergence on
that so
please note that this must be j because
this entity this vector entity that is
given by the index j and we have to
take the dot product of that with the
gradient term so that gradient is given
by this del
del x j okay so the equivalent of this
here would be
del v j del xj
that's what we that's what we are
basically doing here
okay this is equivalent to that okay so
this is the volume integral now
what we'll do is
we will we'll just break this thing
apart okay
by chain rule
just decompose it
so first of all we have del
sigma ji del xj
delta ui and then
sigma ji del
delta ui del xj
pulsing under bracket inside the bracket
db
okay so now you see this first term has
this delta ui
this term also has this delta ui so
we'll take this term common with this
term
and please note i can do that because
all of these are
volume integrals so i take this these
two things together so bi plus
del sigma ji
del xj
whole thing multiplied by delta ui
dv and whatever remains here
is this volume integral of sigma j i
[Music]
del delta u y
l exchange dv all right
now you know that again from our studies
in applied elasticity
we know very well for that for a body
under static equilibrium
we have uh
we know that
rho bi plus
del sigma ji del xj
that is nothing but 0 for a body in
under equilibrium
okay so this is nothing but the stress
equilibrium equations we have studied
this in our stress chapter of applied
elasticity
so we can immediately use this here so
that
what we obtain is
i can go to the next page
this therefore
our delta w is equal to
whatever was there uh remaining the
volume integral
sigma ji del delta ui
del xj dv so let's just check if this
term is correct
so sigma gi del delta ui
del xj dv
all right so now uh we have considerably
simplified it
but we can simply simplify it further
again using our
concepts from applied elasticity so
we'll proceed step by step uh first of
all what we do is
we interchange the order of this partial
derivative and the variational operator
okay so that can very well be done
uh so we write it like this
in the next step and now
uh so you understand that the
variational operator is now operating on
this entire thing
okay so what we are going to do next
uh is a little algebra trick
so uh
what we can what we basically wish to
achieve here is an expression
of the uh the first variation of the
external work
in terms of the stresses and the strings
now as written here this is basically
just the gradient
of the displacement vector so uh
using our understanding or using
our knowledge of the strain displacement
relations we can go back
to an expression of the strain through a
little bit of algebraic manipulation
so what we are going to do here is
so we understand that or we know that
epsilon i j
the string that is given by half
del ui del xj
plus del u j del x i
so this uh you all know from our
discussions of applied elasticity
so this del u j del x i term is missing
the half is also missing let's see if we
can introduce it
okay a little bit of algebra
uh delta
half
del u i del x j plus
del u j del x i
plus half del ui
del xj minus
del u j del x i
that's it
so you can very well check that whatever
we have written here within the square
bracket
that is perfectly equal to whatever was
present here this del u y del x j
because
this half del u y del x j that gets
added with this half del u by del x j
and this del u j del x that gets
cancelled with this
del u j del x with a negative sign in
front all right
so now this bit that can immediately be
written
as
sigma ji delta
epsilon i j no problem there
for the next part
we have to that is carry out a little
bit of more algebra
so uh we're almost there what we want to
achieve
uh just a few more steps so
all right
so many of you who are familiar with uh
work are rather quite comfortable with
index notation uh you almost
know uh i i believe you almost know what
is going to happen with these terms
uh nevertheless uh for the benefit of
everyone i'm just going to go through
the steps
so this first term will remain as it is
through
all through our subsequent steps
now uh
here i just
write it separately here this thing
sigma ji
delta del u del xj
dv minus
integration of now here i'll pull a
little bit of a trick
uh where although i'm multiplying the
sigma gi with this term
but i will write this as sigma ij
so where i am basically using the fact
that
sigma ij is equal to
sigma ji which we have all
seen is true from all that is in applied
elasticity
okay so uh
so all of you are familiar with the
index notation will immediately know
that this term is basically equal to
this term
because overall you see this entity this
entire entity
it is uh having j repeated as well as i
repeated
this overall this is a tensor of order
zero so it's basically a scalar
similarly this one also is a scalar okay
now uh in order to actually see that
this is indeed zero these two terms
cancel out each other what you can do is
for this term you can replace the j by
p and the i by k and here
this uh this i you replace by p
and the j by k okay so
overall what will happen is this term is
going to cancel out
this term okay so you can quickly write
this thing
up because uh whenever an index
is repeated
just like this j here and the i here we
can substitute
them by anything else that was one of
the first things we learned
in our mathematical preliminaries back
in applied elasticity
uh so i can very well write this as
sigma t k delta
del u k
del x t
t v and here what i will do is
i will choose to replace this i by p
and the j by k just the opposite thing
of what i did here
okay so there is no problem because
these two are completely separate terms
so here it is sigma pk
delta del u
k del xp
so you see this term perfectly cancels
out this stem
so all we are left with here is just
this
is this term so
what we obtain finally is that
delta w e is equal to
integration v sigma
we just go back here sigma j
i but we can can write this very much
as sigma i j no problem there
delta epsilon i j
and just as a final check you note that
uh this
entire entity here both i and g are
repeated
so this is again a tensor of order zero
there are no pre-indices here
which means that this is a scalar which
is perfectly consistent with the fact
that on the left hand side we have this
quantity
or this entity work done which is also a
scalar
all right so this relation okay this
this is a very very important relation
uh which we will be using subsequently
for further developments of our theory
and
okay in fact not just in this chapter
but
in subsequent chapters also when on
developing
our our theories and governing equations
for beams and plates uh we will have to
come back to these
uh to this equation okay so this is
basically
the principle of virtual work applied to
uh uh deformable bodies and let's not
forget
that uh as far as the principle of
virtual work was concerned
uh we just had this statement okay so
that is still true
okay minus delta wi is equal to our
delta w
e and since we have just obtained this
relation so let me just write this thing
out
completely for the sake of completeness
all right so we have this thing also
this is what we wanted all right so
in our subsequent lectures we'll be
continuing our discussions of energetic
methods
energy methods uh so the first thing
that we'll discuss believe it or not uh
is the
is the law of thermodynamics and you
will see how uh
how energy methods time with those
thermodynamic considerations also
all right i'll end this lecture here
thank you very much